things you didn't know about tears of
the kingdom is coming out next month but
before that we've got one final episode
for breath of the wild so let's get this
show on the road
some players still haven't noticed that
ancient arrows aren't actually true
ancient arrows they're makeshift arrows
using ancient daggers wrapped to the end
of The Arrow this was shown during the
development of breath of the wild in a
way this makes sense now because this is
a similar concept to the incoming fuse
mechanic in tears of the Kingdom
as you know molduga are weak to bombs
and bomb arrows but this also includes
the bomb Barrel
the pickings molduga are attracted to
any active noises including your
footsteps which makes most players go
for the standard tactic of turning tail
and running for High Ground to use bombs
as noise distraction but this noise
system is more Dynamic than you think
because the molduga will Target the last
known loud location it heard so by
making loud footsteps on purpose then
either Crouch jumping away or then
equipping a stealthier clothing set you
can bait the molduga to your last loud
footsteps before going quiet
all right
you can now easily evade its attacks now
combine this with the remote bomb to hit
them with the old bait and switch no
need to ever Scramble for Higher Ground
when attacking valradania on Death
Mountain with good enough aim you can
use yunobo to actually take out some of
the sentries ahead of you instead
when doing the shield surfing challenge
sell me makes sure that you have some
room in your bag before you leave so she
can hand you a shield prize when you get
back well if you happen to pick up a
shield during your race when you finish
she'll get confused and say she's swear
she saw you leave with room in your bag
before you left Mellie will also look
out for you when you're low on health
when she's cooking by the stove if link
is low on Hearts she'll specifically
recommend you rest up by the nearby Inn
instead of normally advising you to be
careful on the roads at night Nana also
reacts and knows about the Champion's
tunic specifically since her Mentor is
Pura and has told her about the Chica
slate and Link story many places in
Hyrule can thunderstorm but Nintendo
coded most snow regions to never have
thunderstorms such as the hebra mountain
range Gerudo Highlands and mount laneru
but this can happen in several
circumstances naturally such as on Mount
Hialeah on top of the akala tower and
also unnaturally by Moon jumping above
the freezing layer during a regular
thunderstorm this also shows how under
strikes do secondary fire damage as well
you just usually never see this because
while you're wet during the rain being
wet protects you from the fire damage as
well as we've shown before
did you know that water OCTA rocks are
totally capable of being on Land
Nintendo even presumed this would happen
as the OCTA rocks have on land
animations just like Forest OCTA rocks
one strange mystery still unexplained is
the choice developers made about showing
how a dry burnable grass Burns in the
gray plateau in this situation they
clearly show you how it works and how to
apply it in tangible gameplay but after
this situation is barely ever seen again
showing up only in a couple places in
Hyrule such as the outskirts stable the
fire whiz ropes tree trunk and these
random patches found around Mount Rome
it's unknown why this mechanic was
mostly ignored after the great Plateau
if you sit in a fire you obviously take
burning damage but there's a special
weird trick with grass for this if you
want to spread a little Wildfire on your
own through normal grass try lighting
yourself on fire first then Crouch
walking this will continue to ignite
fresh grass around you all the while
keeping link on fire without taking
extra damage basically becoming a
walking Matchstick using this while
hiding in tall grass can miss some kills
on unsuspecting foes
even though you can't stand on them did
you know that tropical tree leaves count
as cover from the rain pretty handy for
making a campfire while it's raining
we've also shown before how you can
stasis a tree to create a makeshift
cover for you to create a campfire well
there's another neat trick to creating a
campfire out in the open during rainy
weather which is to cut down the tree
into a log then quickly switch to a
flame blade break the log and press a
immediately you're then able to use this
campfire as a resting place even after
the flame goes out have you ever seen
what it looks like when a stall enemy
digs back underground
there's one single cooking recipe that
stands Above the Rest in terms of
highest selling recipe in the game one
energizing Beetle plus four Lionel
Hearts makes a recipe with a whopping 2
330 rupee value there's obviously other
ingredients that are better in terms of
farming time to review value but as a
singular cooked item this is as high as
it goes did you know that while link
uses his hands and legs while climbing
he technically only needs his upper body
to be connected to be able to climb this
in a way sort of makes sense this can
let link shimmy along climbable surfaces
and even let you sneak up on some
unsuspecting enemies in certain
situations
foreign
pillars found in some shrines and bomb
Meadow can be destroyed in many ways
including bomb arrows regular remote
bombs and even sledgehammers and a drill
shaft even large enough objects with
enough momentum can destroy these as
well like this large sphere on Bob
Meadow
this is a very common trick among
speedrunners but some casual players
still haven't seen the faster way of
doing these Magic Tree korok seats
removing these fruits one by one to
match the others is a royal pain so
instead just stasis the matching fruit
then cut down or bomb the rest of the
tree
when Reviving a horse with Melania it'll
mention that it died due to an
unexpected accident but did you know
that Melania will change this response
in different ways depending on how it
died it can seize several death
circumstances such as if it died in an
explosion
died to a guardian
or you yourself killed it
bologna will give you the benefit of the
doubt that it was just an accident but
you know you have a guilty conscience
about it there's a strange phenomenon
that only happens during the gerudo's
perfect drink Quest when you transport
the ice block from the ice house to
furosa on the other side of these ruins
exploring the sides of these ruins will
have oddly placed the Goblins surrounded
by floating campfires all staring off
into the distance in the same direction
at night the campfire also lights up on
its own it's theorized that these
bookablins would light their weapons and
would deter link from taking his ice
block too far away from the Center PATH
but it's clear that this was completely
forgotten by the devs and this
undeveloped area has enemies placed
haphazardly all of them staring off into
the same direction like this makes it a
little creepy locations in breath of the
wild and English have mostly been
explained by Zelda lore experts linking
past Zelda history to their names but a
lot of these location names never
mentioned the Lesser known to play on
words and anagrammed locations and you
can kind of understand the meaning
behind these names once you see it a
great example of one one area is to
bantha region where the Rideau reside
many of these strange names in this area
are bird related behind your back key sa
crater is rearranged soggy in Japanese
the word for Heron struck Lake in
Japanese is hashibino Lake also known as
shoebill Lake which refers to the
shoebill storks which struck as an
anagram of stork Tama lake is short for
tamago meaning egg in Japanese roughly
the shape of this Lake dronok's pass is
an anagram of condor Lake Kelsey refers
to a breed of chicken called the silky
chicken stored in a basin and hot spring
refers to start an eye AKA starlings
Byron shelf up north is an anagram of
Robin and Lake tottori references Tori a
bird in Japanese which if then reversed
is rito now is this all starting to make
sense
well after exactly two years and 25
episodes we've reached the final breath
of the wild episode but don't go
anywhere because this series is going to
continue into tears of the Kingdom we
thank you all for supporting us so far
here on Gamespot and we'll see you guys
again very soon in the highly
anticipated sequel
foreign
[Music]